voici le théâtre de l'une des plus
incroyables opérations militaires de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
tentative audacieuse des alliés pour en
finir rapidement avec cette guerre
l'opération associé à une offensive
terrestre est le plus important
parachutage de troupes aéroportées
jamais vu
l'opération se solda par un échec
à cause d'erreurs fatales temps dans la
planification que dans l'exécution
les troupes alliées affiché un courage
remarquable ici à arnhem et sur ce pont
en particulier
mais le courage n'a pas suffi
à la fonte de l'été 1944
l'allemagne est en pleine débâcle sur le
front de l'ouest la conquête de la
normandie et la libération de paris
semble annoncé l'imminente défaite
d'hitler
au début du mois de septembre les
troupes alliées avance rapidement en
trois énormes formation le sixième
groupe d'armées menée par le général
jacobs havers le 12e groupe d'armées
commandée par le général omar bradley et
la troisième célèbre armée de george
patton et le 21e groupe d'armées sous le
commandement du feld maréchal sur
bernard montgomery
la victoire semble assurée mais les
alliés pressante qu'une percée direct au
coeur de l'allemagne serait risqué la
frontière occidentale du raï est en
effet protégé par les impressionnantes
fortifications défensive de la ligne
siegfried
sans compter que l'importance même du
front alliés commencent à poser problème
cet iphone et le 21e groupe d'armées
celui de montgueux mairie par exemple à
la fin du mois d'août début du mois de
septembre
ils avançaient en moyenne de 80
kilomètres par jour on avait donc un
groupe d'armées progressant à grande
vitesse et dont la logistique s'étirer
jusqu'aux plages de normandie à près de
500 km de là en termes
d'approvisionnement
ça voulait donc dire que chaque balle
chaque pièce d'uniformes chaque pièce
d'équipement et surtout chaque litre
d'essence devait être amené tout le long
de ces lignes extrêmement étiré trop
étirer les alliés rencontrèrent donc de
grandes difficultés dès le départ
montgomery n'est certainement pas le
seul chef allié à comprendre à quel
point il est difficile de se battre sur
un fond aussi large
mais son plan pour résoudre le problème
sors dîner
montgomery a toujours été considéré
comme un commandant prudent mais la
stratégie qu'il propose aujourd'hui
radicale et sans précédent il suggère
que des troupes britanniques passent
rapidement la frontière néerlandaise
pour entrer dans les territoires occupés
située à l'ouest de la ligne siegfried
une fois qu'elle aurait passé ce ouest
où lés troupes pourrait alors tourner à
droite et attaquer le coeur même de
l'allemagne
les troupes au sol recevrait le soutien
de trois autres divisions qui arrivait
en même temps par les airs et prendre le
contrôle d'un couloir que les troupes
terrestres pourraient traverser en
sécurité
cette composante aéroportée forte de
près de 35 mille hommes et baptisée
opération markets
parallèlement le lieutenant-général ryan
au rox mènerait son 30e corps vers le
nord le long de la route club
cette partie de l'opération reçoit pour
nom de code garden l'ensemble de
l'entreprise devenant ainsi l'opération
market garden en cas de réussite
la stratégie de monde aux mairies
pourrait mettre une fin rapide de la
guerre peut-être même pour noël personne
ne discute les avantages potentiels
mais quantité de personnages importants
nourrissent de grandes inquiétudes quant
au plan de montgomery
je pense que le plan alliés de market
garden inquiété et préoccupé bon nombre
de commandants certains d'entre eux
étaient des officiers de renseignement
le plus célèbre étant sans doute le
major brian heures car kit persuadé que
la force de frappe des allemands qui se
trouvaient dans et autour d'arnhem à
l'épousé de gros problèmes on comprend
qu'après le succès écrasant remporté par
les alliés en normandie il est puceau
nettement croire que l'armée allemande
et est d'ores et déjà vaincu s'est
déterminée mais les allemands les
prouver tant sur le front de l'est que
sur celui de l'ouest qui n'était pas du
genre en suisse et sans danger
la décision finale appartient à
eisenhower et à ses conseillers
politiques
la récompense potentiel est tel que même
si les risques est énorme
ils savaient qu'ils devaient tenter sa
chance et lancer l'opération marque et
garonne s'il avait réussi l'opération va
certainement entraîner l'effondrement
catastrophique de l'effort de guerre
allemand
le jeu en valait donc la chandelle et
even worse fini par le reconnaître même
vous et mettre fin le plus rapidement
possible la guerre aux europe avec un
minimum de pertes aux alliés se passer
surtout de pertes américaines pour
savoir
le dimanche 10 septembre décision est
prise de mettre en oeuvre la proposition
de montgomery le même jour la division
blindée de la gare de britannique prend
possession de ce pont situé sur un canal
près de la frontière belgo hollandaise
connu sous le nom de joe the bridge il
allait marquer le point de départ de
l'opération qui serait lancé sept jours
plus tard
les ponts situés dans le couloir sont la
clé du succès de l'opération marc
dardenne
cinq de ces pauvres revêt une importance
stratégique capitale et ce sont les
trois divisions et reporter qui doivent
en assurer la brise la 101e division
aéroportée américaine se voit confier la
zone entourant ngô van leur mission
prendre les ponts des canaux où il
élimine inzaghi la mosson
plus au nord le général de brigade james
kevin mènera sa 82e division aéroportée
pour prendre les ponts de grève et de
nimègue le dernier pont serait quant à
lui l'objectif de la première division
aéroporté britannique et d'une brigade
parachutiste polonaise intégrée au
nouveau premier corps aéroportée leurs
objectifs
le pont d'arnhem
le général de division stanislav ce ça
bof ce qui se montre extrêmement
sceptique quant à la mission qui lui
incombe détail lourd de conséquences sa
brigade parachutiste polonaise n'allait
pas être largué le premier jour de
l'opération à cause du manque d'avions
de transport le déploiement du premier
corps aéroportée s'étalerait sur trois
jours et les hommes de ce above ce qui
arriverait les derniers l'élément de
surprise est essentiel dans les
parachutages il faut prendre l'ennemi
par surprise est arrivée à l'endroit et
au moment où il s'y attend le moins a
mené les renforts au compte-gouttes
appliquée que si l'opération n'était pas
succès total le premier jour où
couraient le risque que les défenses
aériennes soient renforcés pour la
deuxième et la troisième vague encore
les mis au sol se douterait qu'il y
aurait probablement d'autres
parachutages et ils seraient préparés à
boudy pop et fono et le teich à cela
s'ajoute évidemment les caprices de la
météo sur ces trois jours alors que vous
êtes déjà en partie engagée
il est tout à fait possible que le temps
vous en perdre amener les renforts au
point principal et c'est exactement ce
qui est arrivé
ces premières troupes britanniques ne
serait jamais parachuté à arnhem ni même
dans les environs chez les parachutistes
et des planeurs ont besoin d'un grand
espace ouvert sur un terrain ferme et
présentant le moins de ce tacle possible
la seule possibilité pour la première
division aéroporté britannique de
trouver ce genre de terrain était de
choisir des zones de parachutage située
à près de 13 km du centre d'arnhem et de
leur principal objectif se poser à 13 km
du pont était une entreprise extrêmement
hasardeuse pour des troupes qui
rappelons le genou devrait ensuite
progresser à pied veut il n'avait que
très peu de véhicules et leur
disposition et ils en perdent iran plus
beaucoup dans l'action le choix même du
site et est donc discutable
étant donné la distance qui le séparait
de la ville d'arles est dans un rapport
bost opérationnel paru quelques jours
après des parachutages les allemands
quant à eux trouvé que le choix des
britanniques étaient plutôt astucieux
il se trouvait en effet à quelque
distance de la zone de drop âge et était
caché par la ligne d'arbres situés à
l'ouest d'arnhem dans ces conditions les
allemands ne pouvait pas déterminer où
calculé l'important est trop gagner ni
localiser avec précision leur lieu
d'atterrissage et ces deux facteurs
combinés de leur permettent évidemment
pas de deviner quel est l objectif
potentiel tard dans la soirée du samedi
16 septembre 1944 200 bombardier
lancaster britannique d'école pour mener
des raids destinée à affaiblir les
défenses allemandes en landes
le lendemain matin quelques 800
bombardier flying fortress américaine se
joignent à l'attack en même temps en
angleterre 22 terrains d'aviation
fourmis d'activité tandis que le troupes
américaines et britanniques embarquent
dans leur avion et leur planeur je pense
que le briefing était excellent comme
d'habitude nous avait rencontré le plan
nous avions de quoi il retournait et
nous connaissions les objectifs qui me
tournait autour de la hourre ayant trait
à l'arrivée du troisième corps il fait
beau comme prévu ce jour-là et à 9h30
les premiers sky 3d cols suivis par les
transporteurs de parachutistes de cotard
dont les airs deux colonnes d'avion se
forment au dessus des villes anglaises
de march et light field chacune met
ensuite le cap sur la hollande selon un
itinéraire prédéterminé le spectacle est
fascinant chaque colonne d'avion fait
près de 150 km de long et 5 de large
plus de 500 planeurs remorqués
rejoignent le millier de transporteurs
de troupes pour atteindre un total de
plus de 2000 avions
le crâne avec la réussite des
débarquements et reporter du jour j et
nous étions relativement confiant
surtout qu'il ne disait que la guerre
serait fini d'ici noël
c'en était en septembre et je pense que
tout le monde était heureux et très très
confiant trop confiant même l'idée d'en
découdre
de notre point de vue il n'y avait
aucune raison pour que cette opération
de soif un succès le soutien des avions
de combat est lui aussi considérable 371
spitfires tempest et mosquitos
britannique et 548 thunderbolt lightning
et mustang américain une fois en l'air
tout se passe relativement bien jusqu'à
ce que nous survolions les canaux sur le
continent où les allemands disposer de
plusieurs barrages armés de canons
entière nous venions relativement bas
aux alentours de 450 600 mètres ce qui
créa une certaine confusion au moment
des tirs anti-aériens au début de
l'après-midi les planeurs commence à
atterrir et les parachutistes entament
leur descente vers leurs zones de
drapage stratégique nous trouvons ici
sur la zone d'europages face à terry la
première brigade de parachutistes et le
général de brigade l'alvéolé faste les
premiers et deuxièmes et troisièmes
atrion il ne savait pas à quoi
s'attendre et une expérience terrifiante
mais il n'y avait quasiment aucun
allemand icig les deux sortes les
parachutages aux enchères à
l'opération marque est commencée bien ce
déploiement alliés pour l'opération
market garden était absolument sans
précédent
il ne faut pas oublier et peut-être que
beaucoup l'ont oublié que la guerre
aéroportée n'en était encore qu'à ses
débuts les britanniques et les
américains s'amuser et jouer depuis
quelques années avec le concept de
l'aéro portée mais l'idée n'avait été
réellement reprises par des allemands
italiens et les russes qu'au début de la
guerre il avait déjà connu quelques
catastrophes majeures du point de vue
allemand il faut comprendre que ce
parachutage s'est fait à l'arrière de sa
zone de combat l'endroit où ses troupes
étaient stationnés est se sont soudain
trouvée confrontée à l'ennemi se
trouvait à deux heures de route en
arrière de la ligne de front
il ne s'attendait donc pas du tout un
parachutage de cette ampleur sur leurs
positions à 14 heures la bataille
s'engage pour de bon
quand le lieutenant général brian cox
ordonne la mise en place d'un énorme
barrage d'artillerie sur le jazz bridge
pour ouvrir la route d'harnes m
à 14h35 des chars cromwell de la
division blindée de la garde prennent la
direction du nord soutenue par une
brigade d'infanterie sur les côtés de la
route au nord les troupes américaines de
la 101e division aéroportée entre
rapidement en action
après une possession du port du canal 2
et willems et force les allemands à
faire sauter le pont de wilhelmina
hauteur de son pendant ce temps la 82e
aéroportée de james kevin prend
possession du pont routier de grève et
se prépare à prendre le pont géant sur
la oil à nimègue cet objectif va
toutefois s'avérer bien plus difficile
il va falloir trois jours aux alliés
pour s'emparer de cette structure de 800
m le deuxième jour de l'opération des
hommes du sein sont 8e régiment
d'infanterie parachutiste manque de
l'apprendre a pas moins de trois
reprises à chaque fois ils sont
repoussés
encore plus au nord la première division
aéroporté britannique a elle aussi hâte
de poursuivre ses objectifs mais se
trouve bientôt retardé
pendant le vol depuis l'angleterre des
câbles de remorquage se sont rompues
entraînant la perte de plusieurs planeur
certains de ces planeur apporter de
précieux véhicules à moteur leur perte
va considérablement réduire la mobilité
britannique dans sa course vers le pont
d'arnhem paradoxalement la population
civile locale devient elle-même un
problème quand transportait d'allégresse
par son apparente libération elle se
précipite à l'extérieur pour ces lui les
troupes britanniques leur offrir de la
nourriture des boissons et d'autres
cadeaux
si cette réaction est tout à fait
compréhensible elle ne sert qu'à
ralentir encore l'avancé britannique
et puis les cartes fournies aux
parachutistes sont pour la plupart
incorrect et il devient rapidement
évident que les radios dont ils
disposent sont sérieusement défectueuse
soit elle ne fonctionne plus du tout
soit leur portée est faible et leur
réception médiocre
il y avait énormément de problèmes
techniques avec les radios à arnhem
alors qu'on savait avant la bataille que
ces radios n'était pas fiable il faut
une des explications plausibles
tous ces problèmes je pense le nombre
d'opérations est reporté qui avait été
avorté avant celle ci est fort probable
que bon nombre radio n'avait pas été
rechargées quand le parachutage a enfin
eu lieu
les soldats ont sans doute découvert
avec horreur qu'ils avaient des
problèmes de batterie et pas de vrai
problème de radio ça veut donc dire
qu'au moment cruciaux de la bataille les
commandants ne pouvait communiquer ni
vers l'avant ni sur le côté univers
l'arrière univers leurs quartiers
généraux en angleterre le plan ainsi
perdu 5 pour 10 nations initial
mechri le matin du 17 septembre
un officier supérieur allemands se
trouvent ici dans son quartier général à
l'hôtel hartenstein duster bec à 5 km à
peine à l'ouest du pont d'arnhem
l'officier en question est le fait de
marshall ou halter monde elle file
marshall allemand mode et son état-major
se trouvaient dans ce bâtiment
et quand les britanniques ont débarqué
ils se sont enfuis en laissant les
tables telquel dressé pour le déjeuner
avec de l'envié et du saumon fumé et les
choses que nous n'avions pas vus depuis
des années les britanniques se sont
jetés sur les places mais ont été
chassés par leurs supérieurs décidé de
s'arrêter là pour la nuit avant de
rejoindre arnhem mais le lendemain
c'était déjà trop tard
le passage est et c'est ainsi que ce
bâtiment est devenu jusqu'au 25
septembre le quartier général la
première division aéroportée ont leur
fait croire aux troupes britanniques que
la région d'arnhem ne serait que très
mollement défendu des enfants des
invalides des vieillards à bicyclette
la réalité est tout autre
le feld marshall modèle organise
rapidement une réunion avec son collègue
willy bit rich le général bit rich
c'est exactement de quelle force il
dispose à quelques kilomètres à peine au
nord et à l'est de la région d'arnhem ce
n'est pas là une arme est branlante
retirez-la après les combats en
normandie
il s'agit des huitième et neuvième
division et ses sponsors les
renseignements néerlandais avait prévenu
les britanniques que des panzers se
trouvaient dans la région
il avait ignoré ses avertissements et
les conséquences allaient être
dramatiques
la quantité de renseignements qui
affluaient dans les différents quartiers
généraux pendant cette fuite précipitée
des têtes de pont normes horn vers
berlin était phénoménal et il a dû
s'avérer extrêmement difficile
d'assimiler de collationner et le
disséminées tout ces informations il
n'en reste pas moins que les alliés
savait exactement ce qui les attendait à
arnhem énorme
je suppose que ce qui les a surpris
c'est la rapidité avec laquelle les
allemands sont parvenus à remettre en
état et rééquiper 2 division de panzers
rempli de fanatiques ses troupes étaient
dévoués corps et âme à la cause nazie
et ce sont ces mêmes hommes qui allait
prouver qu'ils étaient loin d'être un
ennemi
trois heures après le début du
débarquement britannique la stratégie
défensive allemande est en place huitric
envoie sa 9e division de panzers vers
arnhem la 10e vers nimègue
les troupes qui se trouvait déjà dans la
région d'arnhem sont mises en état d'
alerte
parmi elles trois bataillons
d'infanterie et deux bataillons de dépôt
ss sous le commandement du major
septe kraft
cet excellent soldats déploiera pidement
ses troupes pour qu'elles occupent des
positions défensives autour d'arnhem en
sachant parfaitement que les panzers ne
vont pas tarder à venir prendre la
relève
les blindés lourds britanniques les plus
proches se trouvent quant à eux à plus
de 80 kilomètres au sud
la tâche des parachutistes britanniques
s'annonce difficile et leurs chances de
réussite vont bientôt diminuer encore
peu après d'insertion de la première
vague aéroportée un des planeurs wako et
probablement américain fut abattu et un
effet des balles de student un senior nc
au trouve apparemment une copie des
ordres de mission pour l'opération
market garden à partir de ce moment là
et bien que les alliés l'ignorent les
allemands connaissent lui précisément le
moindre mouvement à venir il s'agit
d'une opération très complexe et tant
d'éléments déjà été mis au monde que
même si les alliés s'étaient doutés que
leur plan est tombée aux mains des
allemands
il est de toute façon fort peu probable
qu'ils auraient pu arrêter l'opération à
ce stade
les hommes de la 1ère brigade
parachutiste britannique ignore la
véritable force de leurs ennemis quand
il se met en route pour le pont d'arnhem
un peu avant 16 heures cet après midi là
ils ne vont pas tarder à la découvrir
le général de brigade gérald blackberry
est au commande assistée de son
commandant divisionnaire rude
urquhart 3 bataillon du régiment des
parachutistes sont à présent engager sur
trois itinéraires différents
la bataille d'arnhem est sur le point de
commencer et la rapidité de la vence
britannique serait difficile
arrivé au nord de wolf et le
lieutenant-colonel david d'auby du 1er
bataillon découvre bientôt que les
défenses allemandes sont considérables
des panzers sont déployés et flanqué de
fervents fantassins qui sont loin d'être
des vieillards à bicyclette
ces hommes étaient surnommés les verrues
qu elle met son casque fous ils avaient
perdu leur famille sans doute en prusse
orientale ou suite aux bombardements
ce pays ont plus de raisons de vivre
après la guerre ils se battaient comme
des fanatiques
il n'avait plus rien à espérer de
l'avenir les avait une sorte de slogan
qui littéralement signifie profite de la
guerre tant qu'il peut parce que la paix
sera terrible les pertes des premiers
parra sont considérables et d'oubli et
contraint de s'arrêter dans les bois
sans aucun espoir de pouvoir atteindre
le pont toujours là
au sud le lieutenant-colonel fitch
rencontrent les mêmes difficultés avec
le 3ème bataillon
bien qu'ils aient réussi à battre le
commandant allemand d'arnhem le général
cosin
peu de temps après ils sont eux aussi
arrêtés par des tirs de mortier seul le
2ème bataillon progresse bien
alors que les rues d'arnhem résonne du
bruit décourage les combats de rue sont
difficiles
si vous descendez durant rue et que vous
subissez en même temps des tirs de
mortier et d'obus les soldats ont
tendance à se disperser de part et
d'autre tout devient alors qu'on fait un
point tel que je pense même qu à un
moment les 1er 3e para se sont
probablement tiré dessus
la première division s'étant réfugiés
dans les jardins arrière avec la
troisième division sur sa droite
on perd le contrôle et puis on doit
essayer de repérer d'où viennent les
tirs d'obus et agir en conséquence
c'est pas facile c'est bien plus facile
pour les défenseurs pour les assaillants
le 2ème bataillon emprunter la route la
plus au sud menant au pont d'arnhem près
de la rivière du bar et avance
prudemment le long des rues
à sa tête le lieutenant colonel jon
fosse 1 des parachutistes plus respectés
de l'armée britannique
malheureusement pour fausses les troupes
allemandes réussissent à faire sauter le
pont ferroviaire d'arnhem avant qu'il ne
s'en emparent mai à 20h les 2e para sont
arrivés à l'extrémité nord du pont entre
deux tentatives britannique de s'emparer
du côté sud sont repoussés par les
blindés allemands
bien que les britanniques aient réussi à
détruire une centrale électrique
allemande isolé sur le côté nord du pont
dans une attaque au lance flammes il
arrive au pont le soir du 17 septembre
et il constate rapidement que l'eau est
coupée
ils n'ont que les munitions qu'ils
portent sur eux d'obtenir toute la
batterie
c'est pareil pour le matériel médical et
la nourriture
donc après quelques contre attaques
allemandes
il manque de munitions ils manquent de
nourriture il manque d'eau et ils n'ont
aucun espoir de soutien avant que le
reste de la division de la rejoigne ce
qui bien sûr n'arrivera jamais ou que le
30e corps ne vienne à leur secours
en remontant couloir et en traversant le
pont
dans la nuit du dimanche au lundi frost
se retrancher à temps les renforts le
lendemain matin là t'as crampons avant
l'aube les parachutistes britanniques
combattent un ennemi de plus en plus
fort john frost et les deuxièmes parra
continue à tenir leurs positions au fond
avec un contingent d'environ 500 hommes
une tentative d'assaut des blindés
allemands depuis le sud est également
contré par les mines et les canons
antichars 2e para les hommes de la tyrie
antichars ont réussi à éliminer trois
marques quatre allemands départs nouar
mark iv alors qu'ils avançaient pour
attaquer les positions des parachutistes
dans cette zone 1,6 panzer canons
antichars britannique classic pouvait
s'attaquer à la plupart des blindés
allemands
mais dès qu'ils ont commencé à utiliser
des charges tigre ou des panzers les
plus récents cette arme n'a plus permis
de détruire ces véhicules de face on
aurait pu endommager le roux ou leur je
n'y mets pas d affronter de face
leur blindage était trop épais
finalement c'est l'artillerie allemande
qui se révèle la plus efficace
cela devait être l'enfer les chars tigre
allemand qui pilotait les maisons les
cris des blessés en train de brûler vif
dans la maison
les canons autopropulsés les mortiers
qui détruisait complètement les maisons
fallait condition physique était
épouvantable
pendant ce temps des efforts désespérés
sont réalisés pour rejoindre la position
de frost mais le 1er bataillon est
retardée par de violents combats près de
la gare et de nombreux parachutistes
britanniques sont victimes des snipers
allemands alors que le combat de rue
s'intensifie tout près dans la zone
entourant l'hôpital les 3e para
tente de faire une percée mais ici ce
sont les pièces lourdes des allemands
qui les empêchent d'avancer une fois
encore
les panzers allemands prouvent leur
efficacité dévastatrice 82 ans avaient
été envoyées pour renforcer les troupes
de france toute proche à cause des
problèmes de radio il n'était pas en
contact avec le quartier général à
l'hôtel hartstein le général y croire et
le général de brigade ladurie donc
décidé d'aller voir
ils ont roulé jusqu'ici ce qui était
encore possible à ce moment-là de
l'équipage et rage tout d'un coup ils
ont été poursuivis par les allemands qui
ont dû fuir dans une maison mais ils
sont arrivés dans cette maison derrière
moi ils se sont réfugiés dans le grenier
chars allemands est arrivé s'est arrêtée
juristes
l'équipage est sorti rester là le
général de brigade la de bury est
gravement touché par la balle d'un
sniper et est forcé de se cacher avant
d'être fait prisonnier le général leur
carte restera piégé ici toute la journée
incapable de contacter ses collègues
puisqu'il est maintenant devenu évident
que les émetteurs radio des britanniques
sont quasi inutile il va vous
n'arriverez jamais à organiser les
communications comme vous le désirez
pendant une bataille
à cause du chaos qui vous entoure vous
fait du mieux que vous pouvez
je crois que les problèmes que les
pelotons et les compagnies avancées ont
pu avoir communiqué avec l'arrière ne
sont pas exceptionnels même âge
ces problèmes se sont finalement
amélioré ce problème évidemment c'est
qu'au moment où les communications sont
rétablis et que les commandants peuvent
enfin se parler entre eux les
communications ne peuvent plus faire
grand chose pour améliorer la situation
lorsque les communications s'améliorent
la situation est déjà perdue allez lens
au quartier général de la division près
des zones de parachutage le général de
brigade x reprend le commandement en
l'absence du général leur carte x et
commandant de la brigade parachutiste
qui comprend les trois autres bataillons
britannique parachuté le premier jour
en raison des problèmes de radio x ne
peut pas faire grand chose pour venir en
aide à frost et au 2e para au pont mais
le nouveau commandant c'est que les
renforts doivent arriver ce jour là avec
la 4e brigade parachutiste et les
polonais qui suivront 24 heures plus
tard
mais les pires craintes des alliés
commencent à se réaliser en raison du
mauvais temps en angleterre les avions
de transport ne commencent à arriver
qu'au milieu de l'après midi et les
allemands les attendent
les tirs soutenus des batteries
anti-aériennes et une présence
importante de la loupe fans rendent le
déploiement difficile 20 chasseurs des
scorta liés sont perdus pour permettre
aux trois bataillons du général de
brigade
jo la raquette d'arrivée au sol en
sécurité les conditions météo qui se
dégradent est en angleterre ont eu un
effet désastreux au sol cela voulait
dire que les troupes déjà au combat
serait privé de renforts c'était
particulièrement le cas des polonais qui
ont encore été retardé la brigade
polonaise indépendante du général de
division ce symbole ce qui est parachuté
le 21 ou le juge du 19 face ceux qui
combinent une grande partie des craintes
qu'ils avaient à propos de l'opération
il aurait vraiment eu être concentrés
sur un laps de temps ce qui se passe
c'est que ça prend de plus en plus de
temps pour ramener des renforts pour ce
qui était dès le départ très légèrement
tôt dans la matinée du 29 septembre les
1er et 3e para font une dernière
tentative désespérée pour rejoindre
leurs camarades au pont en se déplaçant
le long du bas rhin sous le couvert du
brouillard quand celui-ci se lève il se
retrouve exposé un feu nourri des
allemands venant à la fois du nord et du
sud
les deux bataillons sont littéralement
anéanti
au nord la 4e brigade hackett subit
également de lourdes pertes aux
alentours de la ligne de chemin de fer
pire encore les troupes au sol ou sud
sont toujours loin de la zone de combat
d'arnhem comme beaucoup l'avaient craint
la progression le long du couloir est
trop lente à nimègue le 500e régiment
d'infanterie parachutiste américain
tente à nouveau de prendre le pont
malgré le soutien des gars de
britanniques qui ont finalement atteint
la zone de combat l'attaqué repousser la
seule bonne nouvelle pour les
britanniques et la fuite de roye
urquhart de sa cachette et son retour à
son quartier général établi à l'hôtel
hartenstein l'hôtel évacué plus tôt par
son ennemi le fait marshall modèle
mais monde et les allemands sont
désormais en train de gagner et au pont
de l'arn m les britanniques souffrent
taïwan il était dans une situation
désespérée ils étaient épuisés
il avait probablement défendu les
maisons qui n'étaient plus que des tas
de décombres et les blessés étaient
soignés dans des conditions
épouvantables cage les provisions
diminue liberté les me connais beaucoup
mieux l'emplacement réel des positions
plus ils doivent attendre puis la tâche
la situation désespérée mais quand faust
est invité à se rendre par un officier
allemand
il écarte tout de suite cette idée son
bataillon se battra jusqu'à la fin
le lendemain mercredi au pont dernière
les obus allemands continuent de
s'abattre sur les positions des 2e para
il ya eu un répit quand frédéric hougard
qui avait repris le commandement de jon
fosse il était blessé a conclu une trêve
afin d'évaluer certains blessés
les allemands les ont emmenés mais même
ça parce que les allemands profité de la
trêve pour établir des positions plus
sur le matin du jeudi 21 septembre 1944
les allemands lancent l'assaut final sur
le pont d'ain m
ils savent que la victoire leur
appartient mais la ténacité des
survivants britannique est remarquable
c'était des soldats endurci et les
allemands les respecte et tellement
qu'ils n'ont jamais osé mener une
attaque concentrés sur nous nous ont
attaqués par petits groupes
les parachutistes britanniques doivent
être débusqué un parent lors de
courageux combat rapproché
à ce stade les allemands faisait sortir
les défenseurs britannique en faisant
exploser les bâtiments les groupes de
combat allemand était beaucoup mieux
organisés qu'au début de la bataille les
événements allaient suivre un schéma
simple d'engagement direct par
l'artillerie lourde il faisait tout
simplement explosé les bâtiments une
fois les façades percée des équipes de
lance-flammes s'avançait arroser le tout
de pétrole y met et le funk à la mi
journée les deux côtés du pont d'arnhem
sont aux mains des allemands
malgré la bravoure de jeunes frost et de
ses hommes c'était vraiment un pont trop
loin force 30 postes tient bon au pont
d'arnhem depuis le 17 jusqu'au 21
récompenses de cette ténacité et de
cette bravoure pour la division entière
on leur a décerné quatre croix de
victoria et des centaines d'autres
décorations pour bravoure le temps
qu'ils ont réussi à tenir ses positions
est remarquable c'est pour ça que c'est
encore toujours considéré comme un grand
accomplissement la prise du pont
d'arnhem par les allemands auraient
peut-être pu être évité si la situation
au sud avait évolué différemment les
forces aéroportées américaines ont très
bien manoeuvré
malgré leur mobilité rendu difficile la
route d'arnhem est réservé aux
britanniques
les parachutistes américains sont donc
obligés de se déplacer à travers la
campagne mais le 20 septembre
les américains ont pris toute leur cible
y compris l'imposant pont routier de
nimègue
cette construction géante a finalement
été prise le jour précédant la chute du
pont d'arnhem au prix d'une magnifique
opération dans laquelle les américains
et leurs alliés britanniques joignent
leurs forces
ce jour là le 20 septembre le 500 4e
régiment parachutiste et la 82e division
aéroportée américaine traverse la
rivière dans des navires d'assaut malgré
la surveillance étroite des tireurs et
demi une fois la traversée effectuée ils
prennent seulement le temps de signaler
leur réussite de l'autre côté de la
rivière avant d'engager le combat pour
rejoindre le côté nord du pont à ce
moment les blindés britanniques
interviennent depuis trois jours le
général au rox mène son 30e corps depuis
jeff bridges vers le nord le long de la
club route le mardi l'avant-garde du 30e
corps atteint nimègue
mais c'est le mercredi à 6 heures du
matin que les premiers chars britannique
commence à traverser le pont
ce qui suit est un coup de théâtre
presque sans comparaison à travers toute
l'histoire militaire le feuilleton
marshall mode elle avait expressément
ordonné de ne pas faire exploser le port
celui ci serait trop précieux en cas de
contre offensive allemande heures mais
la brigade fureur armes elle décide de
désobéir aux ordres effet placer les
explosifs pour faire sauter le pont
alors que les chars traverse il donne
l'ordre de l'explosion mais les charges
ne se déclenche pas le pont de nimègue à
seulement 15 km d'arnhem est aux mains
des alliés mais tout cela a pris du
temps
le général gavin arrivé le premier jour
de l'opération ne peut pas traverser ce
jour là ni le suivant bloqué par une
forte résistance allemands quand les
britanniques arrivent du sud le mardi
le passage vers le nord est bloqué et il
le restera jusqu'à la prise du port par
la suite la progression reste lente
les gardes épuisé par les combats ne
peuvent plus avancer cette nuit là sans
le soutien de l'infanterie et c'est le
jeudi matin que les gardes irlandais et
les gardes gallois partent en direction
d'arles m les américains avaient eu tant
de mal à prendre le pont ferroviaire et
routier et des furieux quand les
britanniques ont finalement pris le pont
de nydegg il y avait plus aucune troupe
allemande entre ce pont et frost dont
les troupes restantes tenait encore bon
on se prend la relève
il ne savait pas qu'il n'y avait pas d'
allemand la division des grenadiers
devaient s'arrêter pour ravitailler et
ils ont dit qu'ils n'avaient pas assez
d'infanterie se sent donc arrêtés pour
la nuit avait continué il aurait
certainement rejoint frost
la nouvelle de la prise du pont de
l'ined remonte le moral du regard tu es
des troupes survivante désormais
retranché dans une poche de résistance à
oosterbeek à l'ouest d'arnhem
l'artillerie lourde britannique au sud
peut maintenant être déployés contre les
allemands qui les encerclent au nord ils
ont commencé à tirer
soutenant depuis la rive sud al awal à
nimègue et il avait une grande puissance
de feu mais il ne pouvait pas tirer
constamment parce que les réserves de
munitions posant problème la route avait
été coupée par les allemands à deux
reprises je pense qu'à un moment il ne
restait plus que trois charges mais
heureusement pour les munitions sont
arrivés nous avons pu continuer il était
temps le jeudi les allemands prennent la
hauteur de westerbork à l'ouest de la
poche de résistance britannique
l'après-midi les parachutistes au
polonais arrive enfin
il se pose dans des conditions
abominables
les allemands tiennent les hauteurs de
vesterbro in il bombarde et mitraillent
les polonais en l'air et dès qu'il
touche le sol
c'est une situation épouvantable pour
les polonais se saborde ce qui entre
rapidement dans la bataille il déploie
ses 500 hommes au sud du bas rhin a
dream immédiatement les allemands
réplique en plaçant deux mille cinq
cents hommes entre les troupes de sauza
bof ce qui est de la position
britannique
les polonais devront traverser la
rivière pour aller soutenir du regard
dans sa poche de résistance
le vendredi 22 le 30e corps fait de
nouveaux efforts pour couvrir les
derniers kilomètres vers arnhem mais est
à nouveau bloqué à aelst les efforts
combinés des gars 2 irlandais et de la
129e brigade britannique ne réussissent
pas à percer les lignes allemandes la
214e brigade et la quarante troisième
division sont également déployés mais
seulement un bataillon de cette dernière
division réussi à rejoindre les polonais
avait qu'un petit détachement blindé de
la cavalerie de la garde royale
leurs cartes et ses hommes sont toujours
encerclées de trois côtés ils commencent
eux aussi à souffrir leurs effectifs et
leurs réserves commencent à diminuer
sérieusement il fallait fouiller toutes
les maisons et récupérer tout ce qu'on
pouvait trouver le matériel qu'on nous
parachute et on ouvrait les grands
paniers
il y avait des bérets des badges et des
sous vêtements
ce n'était pas de la nourriture des
munitions de l'eau ou quoi que ce soit
ce genre il s'en tenait toujours au plan
pas qui était d'envahir l'allemagne et
après cinq ou six jours il nous envoyait
encore du matériel pour une entrée
triomphale en allemagne
cette nuit-là sur les bords du bas rhin
les polonais et c'est de traverser la
rivière dans de petites embarcations
gonflables lors d'une courageuse mission
de soutien à leur allié britannique
retenus depuis si longtemps
il montre maintenant leur énorme courage
en tentant la traversée sous les tirs
violents des allemands
sur la cinquantaine d'hommes qui réalise
la traversée 35 arrive opposition
britannique sur la rive nord
le lendemain le samedi 23
les hommes du régiment de recettes qui
ont réussi à atteindre la rivière tente
de traverser cette fois encore les
pertes sont considérables
même si une seconde traversée cette
nuit-là permet d'emmener 200 soldats
polonais en sécurité de l'autre côté
toute la journée du samedi les forces
durs cartes n'ont pu tenir leur position
que grâce au soutien de la retirer du
cid
le 30e corps a finalement atteint son
objectif et sécuriser le couloir alliés
depuis la frontière jusqu'à arnhem
malgré cela l'opération s'arrête là le
dimanche 24
il est de plus en plus évident que la
bataille d'austerlitz et perdu les
troupes deux cartes
le reste de la division rencontrer les
mêmes problèmes que les troupes de john
frost dupont d'arnhem les chars les
canons autopropulsés et les
infiltrations de l'infanterie de
l'infanterie allemande faisait de cette
zone autour du qg hartenstein comme
disaient les allemands un chaudron de
sorcière dans lequel tombèrent beaucoup
de victimes est très vite
ces hommes étaient blessés ou tués à la
fin les effectifs us domec est fortement
diminué il n'était plus qu'à environ
deux mille hommes
il n'avait plus de matériel plus de
munitions une nourriture un plan de
retraite donc été préparé avec l'aide de
la quarante troisième division à sec ce
qui se trouvait de l'autre côté et des
ingénieurs canadiens et britanniques
qu'il disposait de battre honte
le soir du lundi 25 septembre la fuite
d'arnhem sous le nom de code opération
berlin commence sous le couvert d'un
barrage d'artillerie 35 bateaux font la
navette sur le bas rhin pour ramener les
survivants en sécurité harcelées par les
tirs constant des mitraillettes et des
mortiers
nous avons tous évacués au bon moment je
n'ai pas vu grand chose avec deux hommes
des transmissions nous transportions un
soldat blessé un poste de secours que
j'avais vu ce matin la poste de secours
britannique
mais une fois arrivé on a vu qu'il était
aux mains des allemands
ils m'ont demandé de rester là
finalement j'ai réussi à quitter le
poste de secours
je suis arrivé à l'arrivée en plein jour
et j'ai eu la chance de réussir à
traverser à la nage avec un autre
officier d'être en sanction royale du
régiment dg nous avons nagé ensemble ils
nous tiraient dessus
il a été touché et s'est noyé son corps
a été récupéré plus tard à 5,6
kilomètres de là moi j'ai eu de la
chance et j'ai réussi à traversé à
l'urgence du retrait implique que les
blessés graves doivent être laissés sur
place alors que les panthers roule en
direction de la rivière
les allemands se demander ce qui se
passait en fait ils pensaient que les
britanniques renforcer la tête de pont
pas qu'ils battaient en retraite
les allemands n'arrivais pas à croire
qu'après de telles pertes
les britanniques abandonnerait au moment
de l'évacuation cette nuit là il était
complètement surpris mais le retrait des
troupes atteint son objectif et 2163
hommes sont sauvées parmi eux le général
urquhart épuisé cet implant remarquable
probablement une des choses les mieux
réalisés dans l'opération market garden
ce fut un succès remarquable qui
montrait la grande flexibilité d'esprit
leur carte
deux mille cent soixante trois hommes
sont sauvées pendant l'opération berlin
mais sur un total de dix mille hommes
déployés environ 1200 soldats
britanniques et polonais ont perdu la
vie
au sud les pertes américaines approchent
les 4000 tués blessés ou prisonniers et
l'objectif de l'opération market garden
n'est pas atteint
la ville d'arnhem reste aux mains des
allemands et la guerre se poursuivra
jusqu'en 1945 on les f
que se serait-il passé si les radios
avait fonctionné
si l'ennemi n'avait pas été aussi fort
si le 30e corps avait atteint le pont la
guerre aurait elle était fini pour noël
1944 fut vraiment une grande défaite des
britanniques et des polonais et il ya
saison de choses qui en font bien des
batailles depuis célèbres de l'histoire
faille mais ce partage les troupes
aéroportées sont au centre de cette
bataille et elles ont fait beaucoup
d'erreurs mais arnhem est une de ces
batailles clés qui ont contribué à
l'esprit combatif ainsi que la
réputation actuelle des troupes
aéroportées